you know the man I married and the man
he was after the war wasn't the same
person and I'm sure I was not the same
person leader when I was at 16 and later
on ah but somehow we had a need to each
other because he knew who I was he was
the only person who knew you know you
feel like you come from nothing while
nothing nobody loves you it's a very
strange feeling you need some contacts
I'm connection he was my connection he
was he knew who I was and I knew he was
and we stuck it out we met I don't know
how many years I don't know we're gonna
be maybe 25 for what I mom we've yet to
children and he's very different he
copes differently than I do
and we hear me here to tell you this toy
which is I don't know I don't know if it
was voided I don't know if it was voided
because David you know when I was in
concentration camp and even after I said
to myself you know after the war people
who learn they will know people table
see you know the lamb but did we really
learn anything I don't know we do have
up till this day pass over the special
special season for us in our own home
but I suppose what's lacking is that
extended family in my case that's not
there and talking about extended family
I recover my son of us to be permits
when he was permitted there was no one
on my side yes why my wife has a brother
who's a rabbi to the time his
grandfather and her mother were alive
you know for my mother's my wife's side
but it was no more from my family the
joint uh talking about that I never
discussed it with my son he never did he
discuss with me which thinking back now
I suppose I wanted to protects plain why
I didn't but all kinds of did I want to
protect myself and not to be living it I
doubted i don't i don't think this is
the reason but the fact is that moments
of this sword is a Passover or it's a
Bar Mitzvah or a wedding
you're alone not quite behold but
loneliness has various various aspects
to it I remember after liberation I
suffered probably more from the
loneliness and isolation more than
during the Holocaust period and I
thought about it the other day and I
suppose it has to do with the fact that
after life around you seems to be normal
but you are abnormal well why in the
concentration camps and labor camps
there was a preoccupation with survival
preoccupation with being thrown around
and how can I make the next day but then
after his cult elaboration actually the
realization of liberation was not vivid
he was not real with me for a long time
but I remember 20 years 45 46 47 even
after 48 I would find myself crying and
quite frequently and feeling there's no
one there's no one around me that cares
what I do or what I don't do and many
other aspects to it I suppose has to do
with loneliness feeling of yes I'm alive
but that's day
that's it the rest doesn't matter i can
tell you of course there have been some
not issues but rather difficulties
between my son and myself not in a sense
of becoming hostile to each other but
not the current relationship you would
that I would want to see and I noticed
it during his high school years he's a
brilliant young man is an attorney now
he it was a good excellent student who
went Brandeis graduated magna [ __ ] laude
if I may be proud of but looking back I
missed and I miss it terribly now the
fact that I was too busy and he wanted
more of me I wasn't there now which is
it is it fair to come close to him is it
wanting to be normal so much so that I
immersed myself in my work all kinds of
hours
or what but I suppose these as soulless
cars that i mentioned before they are
with us I suppose we'll be buried with
him trying i hope that i could make a
change my if I may share personal
feelings ebony the next if it lasts a
couple years maybe I should change my
position so that i can give spend more
time with my son w Jesus left simply try
to make up lost years once I read the
report the children of the Holocaust
victims are affected and I asked them
how do you feel about it do you feel you
are affected and I said but mommy how
can you ask such a question of course we
are affected and I said but you know I I
never really told you anything as long
as you were little and I said yes but do
you think we didn't know every time
someone spoke about German source own
you always had a comment and then I
record an incident that happened my son
went to school he was about six and half
seven and at school they must have told
them about the Holocaust and he came
home and he he raised his hand and said
hail Hitler and I did not see anything
but I said you know rupee
don't don't ever say that and he became
very serious and he didn't ask me why
not and he went to the bathroom and
wouldn't come out for quite a while and
so I would knock and I said now what are
you doing there so long come out please
and he came out and his hand was
breathing and custard how did you word
it what happened he said then I
scratched it down so I should never say
it
so I don't know and I didn't tell him
anything and I felt I never I never
really spoke to them by their little yet
I must have conveyed something I
realized it for my first daughter was
born
a very short moment I suspected it might
be something that I'm doing as a
reaction and this was right before right
after I delivered her I delivered my
children myself being a gynecologist
that privilege was very important to me
so I went on a kind of a- pre buying
spree but it was to this free binge I
spent a couple of hundred pounds on toys
and I brought all kinds of toys that you
usually don't fight for a newborn like
electric try okay pedal town I've very
proudly prepared everything in the room
my daughter was three days old when she
came home my life my life looked at the
things and she said okay now why did you
buy all this what do you mean why did I
final distance its child nice to have
toys said yes but you see it will take
years before she'll be able to play with
them the [ __ ] would what do you mean to
take is a child needs toys i just put
sometimes what's wrong with a child
having toys and it took me long time to
realize that's what I was doing I was
finally buying toys for myself
and this was mean the start of my
wandering freely what are we doing to
the next generation